all right this Saturday Cosmopolitan Las
Vegas Nevada for the love of God please
buy a ticket okay there's 30 percent of
the room sold people like oh Vegas it's
a last minute Market well it's pretty
last minute buy the tickets I sold 10
000 tickets to New York I got 300
tickets sold in Vegas what's wrong same
goes for you Kansas City what the [__]
do it I mean there in October the third
week of October at the Uptown Theater
and nobody's buying tickets
yes Georgia for me Georgia May making
Savannah and Athens what are you doing
everyone's out selling you in every
other Market please I love you buy a
[__] dick
christycomedy.com guys tickets for my
special in Chicago on December 2nd went
on sale last week and they sold out uh
on the first day because of you guys I
am so grateful uh that we are going to
add another two shows but that is it I'm
not editing any more than this but this
is the huge announcement right now they
went on sale on Friday
um we are going to do Friday December
1st as well tickets are on sale right
now at savocano comedy.com uh they are
on sale you don't even need a promo code
I am not adding more shows after this
the first two sold out immediately so if
you were waiting or thinking about
getting tickets it's Friday December 1st
those are on sale at sabalcano
comedy.com and I will say because I've
been being asked a lot
the contest still stands if you are
going to any of my tapings any of the
four tapings for my uh stand up comedy
special I'm going to choose one ticket
it doesn't matter where you sit and it
doesn't matter what taping you're at I'm
going to choose one person give you a
plus one I'm going to fly you to New
York put you up in an hotel and bring
you on a set of Impractical Jokers I
want to do that as a thank you to you
guys because I couldn't believe it sold
out so fast so you're still in it to win
it if you buy a ticket savocano
comedy.com right now Friday December 1st
at the Vic in Chicago if you have a
friend that lives in Chicago around that
area let them know again I'm going to
pick one person out of those tapings it
doesn't matter where you sit so grab
those right away the rest of the tour is
also still on sale with tons of dates
um as a matter of fact this coming
weekend I will be in uh
Bowling Green Kentucky uh Cincinnati
Ohio and Toledo and then we're moving on
to Wilkes-Barre Pennsylvania and
Wilmington Delaware in October we have
Macon Savannah and Athens Georgia and
even more and more dates all them up
right now on sale at seattlecounty.com
the Impractical Jokers cruise is January
22nd to the 26th with Eric Andre with
Stevo and we're announcing tons of more
Comedians and bands this coming week
there's only a few cabins left for that
you can go get those at get ship faced
cruise.com that's get shipfacecrews.com
check out nopresh.com
noprushnetwork.com from Merchants
savvalcano comedy.com for my merch I
love you guys thank you so much for your
support I really hope to see you on the
road
[Music]
it's so easy yeah you know we're hanging
um I uh yeah dude I I I really think
that Netflix documentary is like it's a
must watch like I watched it even with
my eight-year-old because I mean she's
eight so you know I was like look at how
these people are living like they're so
happy and she was like she was like oh
um you know it seems like they're all in
a community together and that's another
big thing what they don't put people in
Old Folks homes if you go if you put
your parents in a nursing home the
community takes care of their life
expectancy by 10 years they make it a
point of like if we're all connected
we're all one yes I have a life and a
job and a career but if my mom or dad
needs to be taken care of then that's
part of my life like they forget about
the money and like well this is what and
then it their life expects he goes up
and they also usually even when they do
eventually die it's a much easier less
painful death for them yeah it's just
better can I answer your question do
they delve in no actually I don't know
do they delve into diets in these five
places because I have to believe more
than anything else it's probably the
diet well the number one thing they say
for the diet that keeps people living
long is hellofresh
you any Americans number one meal kid
America's number one okay people live in
100. I couldn't believe it you got a
town in Japan a town in Nicaragua
they're all in
hellofreshold Factor 75.
less than five grams of sugar in most of
those puppies yeah so um
so they're just they're just catching
fish and Grilling and eating and that's
all they're doing well that's also no
butter it's low butter but but again
like the towns in Italy peanut butter is
good for you now well no well it's the
keto diet right they say if you put the
butter in the coffee or whatever but
this carnivore MD Raves about butter
well you'd rather get the Irish salt
you'd rather get butter I believe as a
product you rather get real than like
the margarine or less like you're gonna
go for it just go for it because I think
it's actually better for you somehow
shout out to kerrygold shout them out
that's that's the number one right
number one Irish salted butter
so so what they were they they have um
it's interesting like you know like the
nuclear bomb that got uh dropped on
Japan they said there's a type of sweet
potato like how you I know make sure
that we knew where that went yeah
it helped the sweet potatoes yeah so so
the only thing that was growing through
this nuclear radiation was this purple
sweet potato it like didn't die so these
people in this town I think it was
Okinawa had to eat this purple sweet
potato I just saw a thing about this and
they didn't know that it was it had
these amazing health benefits for them
that they all started Living longer
after the nuke drop because they started
eating this sweet potato so somehow it
gave them this was it like infused with
something like from the radiation it's
day tofu this sweet potato and then
these vegetables and this but I don't
wanna I don't want to do that for 100
years oh [__] Eisenhower told them yeah
that's where I'm at it's it's very
interesting but the thing the food and
then their Community they're always with
each other even if they said loneliness
number one killer bigger than obesity
bigger than loneliness that's the thing
that kills you the quickest the mental
because your mental breaks down the
mental affects everything else like a
lot of time like the grandmother dies
the husband goes that's right
so they're always so they said even the
conversation this woman she was like 105
she was like she was like he was like
what do you think keeps you alive he was
like she was like as I've gotten older
life three potatoes yeah the
conversation she said the conversation
with the mailman the conversation with
the with the you know person at the
coffee shop all that stuff keeps me
alive and or they all drink red wine all
day all day well they have at least one
or two a day
she's flatlining got sweet potato
es
a purple sweet potato yeah yeah so it's
very interesting that they said the lack
of and this lack of and they brought up
because of social media and being lonely
and all that how this is where the
suicide rates coming from this is where
the early death rates are coming from
that you gotta be around people and in
some type of uh Community but that's why
I mean when we go on the road I used to
try to save money all the time like I'll
I'll have the opener there I won't bring
anybody but now it because I'm like I
need someone with me that's our biggest
thing if you're alone it sucks you don't
even need I'm like who cares we're doing
this once right that's just we're all
out there let's all laugh I'd rather be
laughing yes and it happened because uh
our buddy Tom Cassidy we would bring to
host the the driving shows like if we
were driving to Boston or whatever like
I'm not paying for his plane I'm like
we're we're making that much money and
you know breaking even or losing money
on the shows and uh
we were we were somewhere in like Albany
and we had like the best laughs after
the show like sitting around the table
like an Applebee's just in tears like
shoes those drives become memories I
would hate to not have this moment in
Seattle because I want to save 300 or
212 I'm like if I look back in 10 years
and be like I missed out on just these
laughs alone yeah like that's all
because I was trying to save up 200 I'm
like I'd rather break even on the show
and laugh with my friends yeah no it's
it's it makes a world of difference we
didn't know uh obviously you know we
didn't start doing the road until the
podcast started working out and you know
we did a few he did a lot more stuff on
the road but by himself but like here in
the older headline it was like you did
it for a while right you guys sure was
always around by yourself they said it
sucked well like yeah John didn't even
you don't even have to deal because you
by the time you started headlining on
the road you were already big enough for
you selling tickets you had people with
you yeah go on the road you know when I
was selling anything 2014 like to be
alone on a Ramada off the side of the
highway in a suburb of Minneapolis for
five days yeah was like I can't you
start to feel like like
Delilah my oldest daughter was like
months old I was like crying I was like
I can't do this and she was like you
have to do this like you you might not
my one not my two month old
she was like Daddy just getting yourself
a sweet potato
but it's so bad dude it's tough I did a
featuring for like I would go to like
the Chuckle Hut and then you're just
like then you also just get tagged up
with some psychopath headliner but
you're like well I gotta be friends with
this guy because it like yeah it
behooves my career and like he runs like
a haunted house
I got linked up with Chrissy D crying
the couch and then um
yeah it's a tough don't think I'm cut
out for the road to be honest with you I
know it's our career so we have to do
but I don't know that I'm like this I I
even when I get bigger opportunities I'm
fortunate enough to still taking certain
places I'm like even at a time I'm like
I just I I want to just be home I want
to be like in the New York area I want
to just be home like close to my family
and like walking around and going away
with friends or family as opposed to you
know I don't know some people on this
day I shed some tears every time I leave
for like a three or four day like in the
weekend I enjoy it it's still newer for
us so we're like you know what's going I
do like the accomplishment of like we're
going to work this is cool like you know
this is I get that uh but yeah it does
every time like they you know we're like
oh it's like do we have a 12 Day run
coming up where it's like it's [__]
that's a lot it's a long run it's gonna
be fun it's gonna be awesome but coming
back to New York yeah you're like all
right after like two years
my longest run was 21 days away in a row
yeah no family no friends like was it
what did
these guys in a band that is in a
popular band I was telling them that and
they were like 1975. no uh Imagine
Dragons oh I love are you kidding me I
love it man that guy is jacked yeah holy
crap they have gone on tour that's well
the Rockstar they go on tour for over
one year and not come home yeah not one
day come home now he's a family his kids
and stuff yeah yeah they go when I said
that to their manager who's my friend
and he said he goes dude they sometimes
they go on like eight nine month runs
one year he was last year what they did
because they do world tours everywhere
and they just don't come home they just
don't somehow
anybody can fly private try doing the
Thursday late show yeah that's work you
know I think about by the way Imagine
Dragons I saw them perform in
Minneapolis in 2014 they are
unbelievable you've been in their show
they're an amazing one they start the
show and they hit that gong that huge
gong and then they go up and holy could
you see him go up in the air on on uh
strings and play the drums upside down
no I haven't seen that I've seen pink do
that well I saw pink on stress they did
it first I think I don't know oh wow no
I don't know interesting they created
charted
ones that we were on the show one time
and they put us out in front of them to
open for them you know we can't play a
lick it was me and Joe and I was on
guitar and vocals and he was on the
drums and they they agreed to it we were
friendly with them they agreed to it
they played uh Jones Beach sold out was
14 000 and change geez there was there
was but you guys were doing it as like a
joke like a TV show oh my God that's
awesome brilliant right so that's horror
two opening acts that played full like
45 minute sets and then when we were
supposed to go on the crowd boat it was
them and so they lowered the lights you
know when they lower the lights and you
know they start cheering and they do
those spotlights just going all over the
place like you know like five spotlights
and they start going nuts and we're like
oh my God they have no idea that now
we're coming out they already seen two
bands right and they announced it says
Senora Lanza which was the name of a
high school Spanish teacher awesome and
we just went out there and dude people
were throwing [__] at us
and we played another
he's not even trying to do and and they
said go out there and make up the songs
on the spot
so we're just I'm literally making up
the words I'm making up everything were
you dying like I'm so embarrassed a
couple of chords I was no nothing
nothing but I will tell you that guitar
I'm playing I bought with my
confirmation money in June 1987. it's
Eddie Van Halen replica and I never used
it and finally yeah that's really cool
1989 June 1989. you look like you know
how to play you know what you're doing
he keeps screaming drums solo
drums and I didn't know what to do so
I'm making these songs up and they said
they said to call them the imagination
dragons Okay so they're the imagine so
these people are booing us we're the
third people we can't play they don't
know what's going on some people are
laughing some people are throwing drinks
everything and then were you guys big
enough yet where people some of the
crowd knew your show by then or was it's
like season one no this was like season
maybe three okay so some people
definitely knew some new but not not the
whole crowd no one really not enough
most people did not know right they
don't see who
we are and so the and so so first
another thing is they're Mormon all
right and I didn't know this but we're
not allowed to curse sure and I didn't
know this dude I was on stage going I
literally one of the songs I made up is
the uh the imagination Dragons we
imagine and I just said it like five
times I'm like we're better than them
better than them yeah and I had no idea
that they don't curse and a lot of their
cars on the podcast we don't care we're
Mormon here as well and then and then
some guy comes off to take me off the
stage and I thought it was them messing
with me so I'm just pushing the guy out
of the way and he's trying to grab me
I'm pushing him out of the way
so he's put and I'm pushing he's Cur
he's like he's like get off the stage
I'm like no leave me alone leave me when
I keep playing I didn't know it was it
their official tournaments like this
they didn't tell me they didn't tell me
when I had to go they told me to Stage
they didn't tell me when I had to go off
and what happened was
what happened was she just did a pencil
stage dive they were supposed to start
and I did lead them like another like 10
minutes and they were going to go into
curfew and curfew it's time and a half
for every single worker there so it it I
mean it would have cost them like 80
grand yeah it costs more than that more
than that yeah and they their finale is
going up attaching going up all going up
in the sky on ropes and playing drums
all in the sky upside down and if if
they didn't if they cut the show early
then they couldn't do the finale and so
I got pulled off stage and like they're
gonna they're gonna go over curfew
what's gonna because they're gonna have
to go over because that's the finale and
they got charged so much money and then
then the magical dream goes oh you
weren't supposed to curse man and I was
like oh my God so I cost them like six
figures and I just got 14 000 fans but
the true TV pay for they had to put the
show paid for that right no you had to
pay for that no they didn't they just
they just ate it wow yeah what happens
if they're drumming upside down and they
drop a stick uh I guess you just
following strings did you see Schultz
did you see that yeah
dude it was worse than I thought
because he was amping it up I'm like
this is should see selling this story
with the DJ yeah yeah so he's with a DJ
that he's friends with and they have
them backstage and he's
doing some extracurricular problem to
the right there's some extracurricular
activities and there's a bot like a
synth like a digital Bongo that he's
he's like so she stops playing he's like
I'm gonna play
and so she stops playing music and he
starts playing the drums for the concert
yeah and it's we can't play the music
right
it's probably can we play his Instagram
clip him explaining or we can't pimpy
you think
all right all right well it's Devin's
it's just him like duped if you watch
it's devis it's devis like you feel it
and he's saying he's like this is the
biggest bomb I've ever had and because
he went out there because they're like
Andrew Schultz whatever and he's looking
he's playing the bomb what's up guys
this episode is sponsored by Blue chew
let's talk about sexier you want to
bring that heat in the bedroom you can
increase your performance and get that
extra confidants in bed listen up
bluetooth.com it's a unique online
service it delivers the same exact
ingredients as Viagra Cialis and Levitra
but in chewable tablets at a fraction of
the cost sold
you can take them anytime day or night
you can plan ahead or be ready whenever
the opportunity arises process is simple
you sign up at bluechew.com consult with
one of our licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days the best
part done online no visit to the
doctor's office no awkward convos no
waiting in line at the pharmacy you know
that stuff Bluetooth tablets are made in
the USA and prepared and shipped
directly directly to your door in a
discrete package does it work do you
think you need it try it for a month and
see you're going to love it with
Bluetooth men everywhere excited to see
the postman because when your packages
arrive your package has a ride somebody
over there got jokes
um anyway guys Bluetooth wants to help
you have better sex discover your
options at bluechew.com chew it and do
it babes we've got a special deal for
our listeners try Bluetooth free when
you use our promo code hey babe at
checkout just pay the five dollar
shipping that's
bluechew.com promo code hey babe to
receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com more details and important
safety information and we thank
Bluetooth for sponsoring the podcast
guys you gotta go to game times URL you
got to get their app it's gametime.co
and if you don't know what this is it's
an app I use for last minute tickets at
the absolute best prices we love the app
we use the app uh especially when I'm um
visiting somewhere like I'm on the road
and I want to you know make plans last
minute and I didn't have time to do it
months in advance sometimes I'm on the
road and something's happening there
that I'm like oh my God this is amazing
I go to the game time app to to uh to
buy my tickets basically it takes about
two clicks they get sent right to my
phone they have a best price guarantee
um their game time guarantee means
you're always gonna get the best price
because if you do find tickets in a
um the same section and row anywhere for
Less they're gonna credit you 110 of the
difference uh my favorite thing is you
see the view from your seat before you
buy that is one of the biggest things I
can't believe everyone doesn't do that
but they got that right all the prices
are showing up front so you're not
getting hit with any hidden fees and it
is good for everything Sports movies
events concert anything in your area
check it out take the guesswork out of
buying tickets with Game Time download
the game time app create an account and
use code hey babe for 20 off your first
purchase terms apply again what you're
going to do is create an account redeem
uh code hey babe
h-e-y-b-a-b-e for twenty dollars off
download the game timeout today last
minute tickets lowest prices guaranteed
oh God okay that's good no but look at
the crap oh music's off
oh I know all that comments are just
roasting his haircut
thank you
why did the back of his head look like
Moe from Three Stooges
Screech at home look at the comments on
his haircut though can you scroll down
baby that's every single person is
should be more embarrassed about the
haircut that thing's wild bro's got the
Hitler cut then people were saying that
he looked like the guy from he looked
like the guy from Despicable Me the
villain from Despicable Me that's funny
I've never seen it oh dude I was crying
laughing at this because but and now and
then but now as he said he's working on
it but dude it was it was one of those
things on what on the I know he just
posted an Instagram video of oh he's
working on the the Bongos yeah that'll
be awesome if he does a Redemption kills
it it was so funny bro I was like
because like you you know like I don't
know I guess like any of us have gotten
used to a crowd now so if you told me to
go out there and gave me a microphone
I'm like you're messed up you'd be like
this confidence
and then and then you don't but dude
it's it's so fun and it's great he leans
into it it's so it's so funny bro I was
I was literally like crying crying
crying laughing I couldn't stop laughing
you can see people in the audience they
turn to be like what the hell is
the lowest possible thing
I can't play an instrument at all and I
don't think I'll ever be able to same I
don't think I'll ever get it you're
sitting next to a an accredited
oh musician guitar really yeah just a
little like strumming stuff so you would
you would get out there and Imagine
Dragons he's being humble is he being
honest tell us what you do you got songs
I got a couple of songs you wrote songs
yeah you you wrote songs when I lived up
Melodies and chords when I lived up here
before I did comedy
um I came up here to be an actor didn't
was just doing coke working in a bar
started playing started playing baby
started playing guitar playing guitar
wrote a couple of songs and started
doing like uh you know small shows and
like you know like Kenny's Castaways and
stuff like that and then did that for
maybe like a year recorded a couple of
things and then wait you can move time
you sang as well you were yeah oh there
is an opportunity for you if you'd like
to be the guitarist of salsa windfall
wait can you so so you could always sing
uh he's a very talented man isn't it
crazy that a lot of people who play the
guitar can also sing is that calm by
coincidence I I truly believe that's
funny I know that you can get better at
any skill but like follow you were just
born with a talent you were just born
with it in your brain like I couldn't I
could sit next to you every day in
practice and not have I couldn't sing
and I couldn't be able to find the tune
I think you either have that in your
genetic makeup or you don't I wasn't I
wasn't that good with the with the
Rhythm like we were when I would record
I was I was okay
then I stopped I think if I would have
kept pursuing it kept going I could have
started to write pretty decent songs but
I stopped doing it did you sing as a kid
though no no so when did you on when did
you have college that you could sing
[Laughter]
drum solo
I can't
more people if you it's like you know
you could figure it out to an extent the
more people than I think they think
maybe not be mocked roundly when you
sing out loud amongst friends but to be
like I'm gonna write songs and then go
to Chinese Castaways that's nuts yeah
that's nuts I bombed
I'm gonna try to sing tonight on stage
at the comedy seller there you go I'm
just gonna do it in the middle and see
what happens flip it clip it there you
go so we should so so so when did you
think that you can get on stage and sing
with the guitar I don't know how did it
happen I just I just wanted to do it and
just started doing it I was desperate
for attention I don't know I wanted to
do something what did you write about
you got a full head of hair
[Music]
you got a really full head hair I've
never seen it from the side like this oh
yeah yeah good dude you're not even
talking to him you're not even in the
realm of your your fault dude you're
getting you're growing more actually
yeah that's nice you feel good you're
using anything you juicing what uh oh no
no I'm taking the Olympics yeah but I'm
talking to the hair specifically
finasteride Chaser I never I brush it I
never wash it that's the key you don't
wash your hair people wash your hair
every day they're stupid they should
wash it a little bit more because he
sits on the couch in our studio and puts
his head
when's the last time you washed your
hair shampoo and condition yeah what's
never wash
four months ago wow what about
conditioner or nothing just water nah no
conditioner every once in a while I'll
use that how do you keep it smelling
fresh that's a myth it's a myth yeah
your hair is just naturally going to
smell good you put product in it yeah
yeah your hair doesn't stink yeah it's
also a little self-cleansing isn't it
like the oils and stuff yeah it washes
it off I didn't think it was like not in
four months out of four months you you I
think you're playing your own game there
before I learn what do you mean I didn't
think like I was like hey don't wash it
wash your hair once a week twice a week
yeah no four but it depends on you're
like your hand plays it faster if you
have thicker oily hair you got to do it
more mine's real thin Okay and like when
I wash it no dude it's [__] real dry
you're good you're full what do you
think that's the crew it's the the
follicles are things it's not thin his
hair is just I was gonna say because
it's he's got thinner strands I was
taught about only not washing your hair
that much I used to if I took three
showers a day I shampooed and
conditioned three times a day anytime I
took a shower I put shampoo and
conditioner in my hair
like last week just for the heck of it I
didn't wash I didn't I think it's
different for different like Italians I
think that your hair would get a little
because it's thicker it would it would
be I get oily yeah we get oily yeah so
you have to mine is it was the is the
opposite you know my dermatologist told
me you only really have to wash your
armpits on your ass you don't have to
wash any other part of your body your
armpits it's the last time I go to a
doctor under the bridge
hobo Joe told me that yeah
he's the one who told me sunblock gives
you skin cancer
be like me live in the subway tunnels I
would say feet hands balls and face up
pretty big ones yeah you did say feet
sorry he said arm I don't do my feet and
the grundle underneath the nuts that
would be I think that counts as if
you're a genitals genitals armpits and
he did say feed everything else you
don't have to wash you don't have to
wash your chest you have to wash your
arms
my nuts have the shelf life of a
carnival goldfish dude this is
yeah I yeah I I don't know I'm uh I also
don't use a loofah I've been what I've
been doing now is body wash
I wash myself with my hands I'm a borrow
soap man
I have every option and I go by how I
feel that day I get that I respect that
respect yeah you don't use sugar scrub
or anything like that no I used to do
apricot but I would wash my whole body
with remember that apricot scrub
everybody was using it it's uh Saint
Ides yeah it's right every Hot Chicken
what is I have it
45. I've seen something it is
I'm just saying okay apricot scrub can I
tell you something I bought it and I can
see the bottle I'm not joking with you
I'll bring it in I will bring it in next
time I bought it in high school it's the
apricot scrub I bought it I I'm telling
you 30 years ago it is you still it's in
my mouth it's in my medicine cabinet of
my house right this second no no and it
still is a pristine like the day I
bought it wow because you don't need a
lot it lasts me 30 years and I have all
the products but at one point I will say
I switched over to like let's see how
long I can keep this sure but wait a
second so you're bringing the same
bottle of apricot scrub moving different
houses putting it yeah wow well you know
you bring it you bring it
on his 21st birthday
[Laughter]
yeah can you uh can we hear it yes yeah
I'd love to hear it I want to compare
this to salsa windfall and Joe deroses
so it's uh the disguise H Foley it's
very good imagine he's like
I
saw ricotta Salata on a menu the other
day and I laughed out loud
it's an asterosa it's a lineup like a
firm firm type of a pimpy at the TV uh
got disconnected
yeah
um yeah I don't know I guess yeah fetish
kind of thing what ricotta Salata
ricotta Salata yeah is that a real
cheese yeah yeah no no it is that's one
of Joe's songs
it's in salads that's where you find him
most you can find it oh my God sounds
good yeah it sounds good right you like
a burrata I love now actually really I
hear it as Rick colada salada
about two to three weeks ago my whole
life
two to three weeks ago
years decade dude I did not see weeks
dude I swear to God I recently started
to get into it my we were going to have
Chas palmettiere who's going to come
over with his wife we're going to come
hang out last minute I think we had to
cancel it so I forgot why there's a big
rainstorm and they couldn't make it down
to our house but Jazz you know wanted to
have a nice spread out for it for Chaz
she got all meats and cheese it's called
meats and cheeses sliced up bread she
had yeah charcuterie board did I see
this somewhere online did you show this
I might have because I'm up again it's
just two to three weeks ago I only
started eating the meats and cheeses I
looked for it now
in my life would eat a piece if I ate a
piece of cold cheese I could only have
it melted on eggs or melted on Pizza I
couldn't eat a cold
I got a nice little recipe for you
cottage cheese go get yourself some
cottage cheese almond butter cinnamon a
little bit of dark chocolate mix it up
in a blender freeze it overnight a
healthy protein packed pudding money
yeah where'd you get that can you shout
out Jake Owen Jake follow Jake Cohen I
got great recipes I got a cookbook out
Jay Cohen I follow all I don't forgot
what his Instagram Jake Jake
yes hold on because I just want to know
portions could I I'll probably whip that
up no no Jake let me confirm let me
confirm it right here it's Jake it's I
am back on it you never had a fresh mutz
though
I like the cousin of the fresh moots
yeah you break that thing open the cream
and all that yeah but yeah you could
pound one of those very easily easily
fat content on back it's cold don't J
Cohen really if it's on a menu at me and
my I gotta get it what is it yeah
that Timmy D sent us to that it's just a
it's a ball of barata and brigoot
nothing else a little bit of olive oil
you can bloated Timmy do you ever go to
Don Angie's with you that's the first
time I went to Don Andrews in New York
City the lasagna they're like hockey
pucks unbelievable you want to take one
and throw it out the waiter
Five for Fighting yeah yeah
um but you have you tried burrata I've
tried it seldomly I don't love it but
I'm in on I'm telling you he's an uncle
Jesus I'm in on cold cheeses and I
wrapped them you didn't grab a slice of
American when you were a kid and knock
it very rarely and when my kids very
rarely my kids would have been doing it
and I'm doing that in the thumbs you're
a real suspect
but if you pop that sucker in the
microwave I'll eat it but now I'm
different now I'm I'm in the cold
cheeses Chrissy cold cheese
by the way that just that just brought
back an underrated forgotten memory very
simple
you take two pieces of bread slice of
American put it in a toaster oven
how do you avoid it dripping down the
bottom just put one slice of cheese on
there just get a little bit just a
little bit toasty soften it up I guess
that's crazy good it's not quite a
grilled cheese but it's all right my
cousin but the cheese doesn't just get
hot and drip right toaster oven
I was like wow
and over a regular oven all day
never had a toaster oven when I was a
kid they are awesome toaster ovens is uh
it's a must in the house I'm telling you
I'd rather have a toaster oven if I'm
making toast I'm using a standard
toaster of course if I don't want to
fire up the actual oven I don't want to
I don't cook but sure then we throw it
in the toast or off it's a nice sort of
reheat or a slice of pizza out of the
fridge but usually I eat that cold too I
like that cold pizza I love cold pizza
but it was previously it was previously
melted oh okay but now I'm into it now
I'm into it that's even [__] weird no
I get it I understand
yeah what I don't get what I mean I have
no idea it coagulates and then you're
good reheating the coagulating I have no
clue I still won't eat goat cheese
though I don't know what it is something
grossed me out about a goat I don't know
what it is it does have a muskie I don't
like it I don't like it at all I like it
blue cheese blue cheese but yes blue
cheese I'll have nothing to why I can do
blue but nothing too yeah
yeah those cheese fairs and stuff cheese
festivals and it's all that stinky
cheese who's got the best charcuterie
Border in New York City because I'm new
to the game two to three weeks
I would have to assume one you make at
home would probably be the best nobody's
out there
all the Italians is really good quality
Italian Guys is really good so maybe
I'll go there but that's got to work
actually that's a sister restaurant huh
would you do the whip ricotta oh God
yeah
I don't want to go to dinner after this
what do we got I got time I got three
hours I can't I gotta go yeah all right
yeah we gotta weigh ourselves you didn't
never did it I did fresh much okay but I
don't count that as cheese interesting
okay
yeah
sandwiches
three weeks ago that being said there
are five cheeses I've eaten cold my
whole life that I don't consider cheese
that's crazy
you know what I mean no foreign
okay look at that how many years ago it
falls this was probably 2007 I was in
the throes of a [__] bad cocaine
addiction oh my goodness this is in
Philly huh this is in Sunnyside Queens
oh wow wait who's playing the drums
drum machine
here we go
and stand up you had started your
stand-up career ready
right this is you it's me that's your
voice
oh my God
there it is the last time are you
kidding me
[Music]
the whole life yeah
do you want to make the new intro song
for hey babe it must have been
fascinating when you realize you can
sing like that was it fascinating I
never thought it was really that good to
be no fully this is a man this is
awesome dude look at that reading a
little Colombian newspaper
you're holding a perfect note
I didn't know you had my child's mother
in the video
hey Jazz also the song is good like you
know how to write it so how'd you know
how to write a song and you did this
whole thing by yourself everything yeah
this guy this one yes
I recorded this on my Mac
no the garage
[Music]
dude this is all I I like love this song
thank you
there it is there's the Foley we know
yeah sleeping on the subway
wow who's this that's my buddy what's he
doing now I don't know uh he's a
professor is he yeah nice my best friend
growing up what subject English okay
he looks like he's preparing for a
sexual assault on this
[Music]
dude this is awesome
I love it
oh there you go this is hot
[Music]
ter baby
wait I'm sorry does she like him or not
she does okay I it's me completely
misinterpreting a situation okay oh
gotcha gotcha
oh amazing how do you shoot your fans
have seen this already right I think so
we played it on uh something before
legionist ganks oh yeah they buried they
weren't they were so receptive to it
[Laughter]
guys I love butcher box I don't just say
it because they advertise I've used it
since they started advertising it's just
so easy I don't like going to the
grocery store I don't know how to pick
out meat and proteins for Real uh and
this is just easy way to find high
quality meat and seafood that you can
trust it's the 100 grass-fed beef free
range organic chicken wild caught
Seafood all the good stuff you mainly
raise no antibiotics no hormones it's
delivered right to your doorstep it's
always free shipping and you can curate
it to customize your box you could
choose from boxes that they have
um they are better deals and better
pricing than the local grocery store uh
I I uh I had to pork chop a Heritage
pork chop
um recently from them and I
I forgot that I had pork chops pork
chops in the freezer and it was too late
to order anything like what are we gonna
eat and I opened it up and I saw and
man they were good they were really
really good I trust butcherbox all the
way
um they're giving you guys a special
deal today so if you sign up today at
butcherbox.com hey babe and you use the
code hey babe and get 20 off your first
five months that's 100 off okay code hey
babe at butcherbox.com hey babe to claim
that deal if you sign up today at
butcherbox.com hey babe and you use the
code hey babe and get twenty dollars off
your first five months that's a hundred
dollars off okay code hey babe at
butcherbox.com hey babe to claim that
deal this show is sponsored by better
help no surprise there guys okay
um listen if you are a therapy veteran
if you've never tried it uh I think a
good way to start or a good way to
continue uh is with better help it's
online therapy completely online okay
it's designed to be convenient and
flexible for your schedule it's super
super simple you log on you fill out a
questionnaire quickly and they match you
with a licensed therapist and that's it
you could switch therapists at any time
no additional charge
um you know I use therapy all the time
because I think it's really important to
flush out what I'm thinking
um a lot of times I'm so busy that I
hold these thoughts in my head and I
don't process them and I don't get them
out and you would be surprised how much
just speaking for an hour about what's
on your mind on a regular basis how far
that goes so if you're someone who you
know is just an overthinker or has a lot
on your plate or just wants to feel
maybe like get in touch with yourself a
little bit more I've done it it's worked
for me uh try it out um
let's see here get a break from your
thoughts you know with better help visit
betterhelp.com
hey babe today to get 10 off your first
month so that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash hey babe okay thank
you for sponsoring uh the show better
did you have that thing where your
singing voice is a departure from
yourself yes yes now is that something
you cultivated or that just happened
when you open your mouth uh no I think
you know I I was I was locked in that
apartment for probably two years just
writing songs and just doing drugs what
and just kept practicing at it all right
that was it you don't you don't seem
like you give yourself enough credit
I mean I don't know I never I never I
never had the con I never thought it was
that good to to you know keep moving
with it right does that make sense I
didn't have the confidence in it yeah I
mean and you wrote a great song and you
sounded great thank you buddy let's yeah
that's crazy dude that was pretty good
you still you still just mess around and
sing at home and stuff and not not so
much as I saw the comedy that was right
before that was probably a few months
before I moved home and started doing
stand-up okay so and now and now you're
gonna do an in-study acoustic version of
it sure yeah MTV Unplugged and until
he's unplugged dude
I wrote that song you should you should
sell tickets and do an end to these
unplugged and toady's unplugged in the
studio
yeah that'd be all right tickets are ten
thousand dollars
I wrote that I had I had the Riff but I
didn't have any lyrics for it and I
wrote that right after my brother's
wedding because I was like I said my
brother was doing real well he was
getting married and I was bottoming out
in New York and yeah that looks like a
nice air mattress my sister-in-law is
maid of honor the first time I met her I
had I had been doing coke for like three
days and I checked myself into the
emergency room at Bellevue just to make
sure I was okay and then right after I
got out I met them for lunch and I was a
complete mess when I was there and then
I did my then at the fast forward to the
wedding I wrote this best man speech
that would that I still give to people
that murdered great best
absolutely I used it really boys have
used it we give it to the fans yeah
because it's it's like a you know it's
just a quick thing to do at the end to
make sure you have it to put a bow on it
yeah and after that happened this girl
came up to me and she was like my God I
had no idea so when I had like she could
see me when I lose the disguise of being
a complete [__]
oh okay I didn't know that was the
impetus that was the inspiration yeah
and then I went home literally picked up
the guitar and it looked the whole thing
just came out like it was if I would
have kept pursuing it like the the
arrangement's not good it's just the
same chords over again right there's a
kid that did a cover of it that's really
great oh there was yeah yeah it was
really good so you're saying that whole
song that whole thing you wrote In Like
A few hours like in a Sprint of
inspiration type thing see if you can
find that just just to hear the com that
right down there listen to this kid do
it did this guy's H Foley cover yes
let's listen to this kid
good hair will we be allowed to play it
on here yeah I'm sure he'd be cool
within 100 percent
perhaps you think I'll take it down
now is this a fan yeah a fan
[Music]
but the song is good yeah it's a good
song it's it'll be in your head yeah
it's in yeah yeah our first podcast he
did he made the intro and reuse songs of
his for the art the first time we
started doing a pod
[Music]
when I heard him do it I was like oh
[__]
you know it made me realize that you
know
that it you know that there was
something there yeah yeah like you saw
it a little more realized yes like I
could see a music video of that version
of the song right you think you'll ever
do a music video of it I did I mean the
the one with me in the super you know
what I'm saying I'm saying like a new
one like an updated one I don't know
probably not no I don't know I'll be in
it
that guy with his shirt off she
[Laughter]
dude I I took a flight home from Seattle
um the other day and I was like gone on
that 6 a.m flight and I I got home at 2
30 and I was like I'm gonna stay up you
know like I haven't seen my kids in a
week whatever and I was like we'll have
a whole day we'll do this we'll do that
I we I ordered pizza we ate pizza I fell
asleep on the couch from like 3 30 to
like eight o'clock at night and my
family was just sitting around
guys I'm sorry is this Sunday by any
chance was it Sunday football was this
Sunday it was Sunday it was yeah we had
a parallel day really yeah I was
supposed to have a 6 30 a.m flight the
next day it got canceled I drove through
the night from Syracuse home like four
and a half hours my car was at Newark I
went home I'm like I'm gonna I'm gonna
relax all day today I'm gonna stay I'm
gonna I'm gonna watch football I'm gonna
do this and I just literally ate
something fell asleep on the couch for
like five straight hours yeah
[Laughter]
no I got I got berated for that I got I
got but she let you sleep she didn't
wake you up no she let me sleep but it
was like you know she was she was Max
she was like well dude if you wouldn't
have went out to dinner after your show
then you wouldn't be sleeping on the
couch I'm like no I still would have
been sleeping on the couch I flew across
the country at six o'clock in the
morning it had nothing to do with the
dinner even though I did put a few back
yeah we had a nice dinner we had a we
went to this place called the pink lake
or The Pink Door in Seattle phenomenal
okay phenomenal it was I've heard of it
pink it was awesome it's like so
inconspicuous it's like down an alley
and then it's like literally a pink door
and then you go out and the view is like
of that Puget Sound yeah gorgeous and
the food was Next Level we'll clue you
into it
um Tom it might Tommy my tour manager
Tommy Wheels Tommy comedy Tommy will
Tommy Tommy Wheels Tommy Wheels dude
Thomas
I bought tomity was tomity it was it was
a nice thing tommedy's he's got uh Nike
Blazers beat to [__] I mean these
sneakers are beat to [__] and I and he
was he was like oh my heels hurt right
you just mentioned it so then my hotel
was right next to the Nike store so I
went in and I bought him a pair of Nike
blazers just thinking yeah whatever like
we did I mean when you buy somebody
something that how it makes you feel is
like like you just get instantly happy
because you're like this person I just
bought him shoes I didn't I was like hey
dude you need new shoes yeah you can't
be walking around with homeless feet you
know you represent Chrissy D over here
yeah I got homeless pimp I got homeless
feet and and so and so uh it was nice to
see how appreciative it was but the
interesting thing is he took the dirty
sneakers and put them in the new Nike
box and then took the dirty sneakers in
the Nike box home with him I'm like
that's weird get rid of the snake throw
those out always throw the sneaker I
leave them in the store that's crazy
that's crazy goes can you throw these
out for me which is egregious
that's egregious dumpster in the back
and what what do they say sure no
problem yeah you wear shoes out of this
no they talk about you after you leave
shoes out of the store I get but you
take them out you throw them out on your
own accord in the Box though what you
put them in the box he gives them his
socks
[Music]
let me ask you this this is actually
something that is right up your alley
guys my father does this if he's holding
garbage let's call it a coffee cup and
you know whatever and there's no public
garbage can around he'll go into a store
like a bagel store and throw out his
garbage in the bagel store but not buy
anything from the store can you do that
yeah that's cool
[Laughter]
uh you're getting no problem he's doing
something good though let me ask you
this as a homeowner all right if someone
drops into your garbage outside yeah you
cool with that no problem with it like
you know not a not a bag but like you
know just open up and drop something in
there no problem don't throw like you
know I have eaten chili dog in there and
then I get all your stuff on the Raccoon
If It's Paper product or a wrapper or a
real store sure but don't don't mess
don't mess me up yeah yeah dude I have
to start putting bricks on top of my
garbage can because these [__] record
hey babe raccoons they lift up the lids
and they drag the trash out they one of
these raccoons dragged a bag of trash
into my pool oh yeah then I was like
what the hell
yeah dude they could be real mother hey
babes uh seriously and possible
listen it's your house you have to
figure it out I said I can't pick that
thing up and then my family was looking
at me like Dad you have to pick that up
and I was like I cannot pick that up so
he called Sean the contractor he came
and got it yeah
he billed me for that would you contend
that the possum might be the ugliest
animal
yes the babies are cute the babies are
cute foreign
now I disagree with them being cute
that looks cute but maybe when he opens
his uh my mouth
it's the size of a thumb oh that's cute
their teeth are jacked up yeah oh okay I
don't know some of those things are
really cute How does it go that's a
pygmy that I mean that really gets from
something that that adorable to the
ugliest thing I've ever seen
it's they give you the heebie Jesus and
they don't move yeah look at that thing
dude we were driving from armadillos we
were driving uh Tommy Wheels was driving
from Portland to Seattle and we saw a
mountain lion dude mountain lion in the
middle of the night oh my God they're
pretty big yeah yeah did you see it uh
somewhere uh somewhere in the state of
Washington just walking on the side of
the road yeah
and we have natural lines mountain lions
mountain lions
New York he said that was a mountain
lion kids dude at school and when
growing up like outside of the outside
of Philadelphia not even like super
Urban you know not like rural yeah
uh no sidewalks not gonna live long
live in a Red Zone yeah
he does live in a Red Zone the way they
vote shout out to it
what's right 2024.
there would be mountain lions it would
be exciting so like we wouldn't have
recess they'd be like there's a there's
a mail line they were talking about a 45
year old woman had outside of Philly
yeah the suburbs some of the teachers
are they come down from like the Poconos
or something and they make it down this
is Angelina stopping by the school you
boys stay in your lockers that's crazy
yeah look at this thing that that's a
real dude you think he's walking in the
Hollywood Hills it's no no they're
they're everywhere you go on a hike
you go when another one goes there
though you I stood there people get
people get mauled they get jammed up so
what do you got to do for protection
handgun that's no just gotta flash it
they get scared
so then how true real question how does
anyone uh hike right there Then wave
your own crazy I would never go up there
I don't think they I don't think they're
like rattlesnakes and [__] up there wave
your arms slowly and speak in a firmly
loud voice listen to me yeah
today is not a good day excuse me look
then they tell you if if if it if
looking bigger doesn't work they tell
you just go medieval start throwing
stones and branches whatever you can
just start throwing [__] out of it you
abort the plan and go polar opposite so
quickly yeah
so that's I mean no that that when
you're walking through any of those
houses branches no they'll they're in
when you're hiking they're there they're
just sleeping and they typically don't
attack humans but they are there always
there there always around you hike all
the time have you seen one
I can't believe anyone sets foot up
there they kill animal they kill small
dogs
coyotes too they jump don't they jump
The Back Fence and you know get little
balls and stuff for the first time
I saw one in London I saw one in London
running down the street I was peeing all
I was like we were walking over from the
bar I was like peeing behind a car and
this little thought like you know just
started trotting along it's scary
just a fox in the city hey it's a small
little pecker you got there man
uh next year it was the conversion rate
I'm going to London for the whole summer
next year really I said to myself you
know I don't think this is going to
happen but no it is am I bringing my
family okay I'm gonna go on a tour of
the UK like how if I was living in New
York and you're doing shows in Boston
and Philly this time I'm going to do
Manchester Birmingham Edinburgh but
we're just going to live in an Airbnb in
London for like two and a half months
yeah Jasmine already approved the family
once it's approved so you want to travel
so you're gonna go you're gonna just do
comedy over there you're gonna go to
your shows and come back well they're
going to come with me the whole point is
is like they'll be with Oh you mean like
when I'm doing the show yeah yeah on the
weekends yeah I'll probably just go do
the show like at your house exactly
right but then during the week we're
gonna do [__] off during the week
whatever we'll go to like you know
that's the thing when you're living in
London like if you want to go to Greece
for three days it's like it takes like
two hours to get them
one night on the end and then spent uh
you're the king of the one night
I flew into the little crowd work and
got the hell out of there and then we
did uh four days in Santorini which was
[__] what was it what was that what
was I always did I asked my kids this
this is hard I asked my kids this every
day or at least once a week what was the
best moment of the trip
the best 10 seconds of that trip not
sexual
they're definitely lasted four
don't worry
we were we were literally
on the edge of the Caldera like over a
cliff looking out directly west into the
Sun and we were just sitting there
watching it and it was it was [__]
unbelievable wow it was so beautiful
yeah yeah it was a moment you know it oh
you know when you're in it it was good
yeah it was awesome and getting over so
every time we go away she like you know
Rent A Car get let's get ATVs let's do
this and I'm always a a [__] about it
because I'm scared and this time she's
like let's get a a buggy because there's
big buggies
like a dune buggy and I I was like fine
let's do it and it was literally
beautiful the coolest thing Sunset
coming out just zipping around [__]
Santorini open air [__] me and her
it's all quiet the sun's coming up a
nice Greek Sunset and then you're like
disguise
[Laughter]
I rented a compact car in Santorini went
to the black Beach do you know that
beach yeah
[Laughter]
was stuck really yeah literally I had to
get a guy like 20 people tried to help
me with it for hours I I got a guy get a
pickup tie a rope to his truck in my
truck and they snapped at the end of the
day it was like four or five guys had to
get on there and push and I got I got
out of it we were stuck for hours
it was like how cute were the babies
there what's that how cute were the
babies no the black Beach
[Music]
beautiful gorgeous the women they were
beautiful in in Greece yeah yeah what
there was a there was a thin line I did
hear it they're gorgeous yeah you know
European you look like uh Peter O'Toole
Peter Boyle I heard My Big Fat Greek
Wedding three stinks yeah my mom is like
she's she does not talk [__] my mom
she's going to see the movies she's
always positive she was like that
movie's horrific don't go see it wow she
doesn't like it at all oh interesting
it's tough right because the first one
hit like a ton of them
that movie is up there with Wedding
Crashers but that's the thing if they
made a Wedding Crashers too sometimes I
did did they make a wedding they made a
three no no no
but you can't do if you have a classic
you just can't yeah you can't do it you
can't do it and I I feel bad because
then it starts to you know well they did
too and I too was okay I've never seen
them I haven't seen three so I'm just
going but my mom is typically like she's
good she's great because she's so nice
she'll be like oh it's fine you know but
she was like Duck Chris I heard uh if
you if you know what I heard I heard
something about the storyline if you
want to know tell me I know it's a big
deal maybe happening too tell me baby
girl
no if Jones in it right
uh
all right well he was in there in the
trailer yes he comes out of the closet
uh in third one or maybe it's the second
one I don't know oh really and that's
his character yeah I don't know I've
never seen him let's check I heard it's
good though oh you heard three is good
no I heard the first one's good oh you
never seen the first my big no never saw
my picture no reason
[Laughter]
I was always like
hey I love a rom-com yeah you know what
I was just chastised about not seeing
Silva lining's Playbook
okay gotta be honest with you
I've seen about half of it okay great
another good part of the Cooper I mean
I get it this Tucker's brilliant in it
not my cup of tea it's good [__] in
it yeah oh okay you want a good uh
Bradley Cooper's character ah [__] I
can't think of the name of the movie a
really good romantic comedy Oppenheimer
with Hugh Jackman and Ashley Judge
Ashley Judd
um not returned to me it's complicated
something like that you've seen those
right it's complicated something's got
someone like you someone like you okay
it is
I met her once I didn't meet her I saw
her at a party Amy Schumer was having
like a Christmas party eight years ago
and Marissa Tomei was there and it was
it was funny Marissa Tomei is there I'm
looking at Marissa Tomei and I'm
thinking like I'm so like she's so
beautiful and I'm like oh my God like
imagine I fall right now and then like
clockwork Marina Franklin is walking
with a full plate of like hors d'oeuvres
and falls over the coffee table and dude
here's the imagine this you're at a
party with Amy Schumer right there's a
big celebrities you're a comic right
you're walking it's all over a coffee
table baseball slide everything
everywhere and you fall directly in
front of sitting like this Keith
Robinson and Jim Norton
yeah it was [__] hilarious it was and
I I could have and then I had stepped in
dog [__] I didn't realize I stepped in
dog [__] club soda Kenny was the
security guard I was standing with them
talking and goes whatever and I was like
that's my worst nightmare
and
then he goes you step in [__] and I said
yeah I'm doing pretty good
I don't like to brag I'm the stoic
They're bringing back guy
They're bringing back guy cord I get two
more seasons I heard the news thanks
Kenny I appreciate that and uh yeah and
then he said you stepped and [__] and
then he asked me I had to leave yeah
and then I said and I was there with
Phil Hanley I'm like fill in I'm like
where do you go next he goes I live here
I said excuse me he said yeah I live in
the guest room dead serious Phil again
they live there
it was a beautiful thing Phil Haley
lived in Minecraft the real world Phil
Hanley lived in my apartment for like
six months really pays his rent on time
great guy fell him God bless never not
even not even a [__] hour late with
the rent ever sharp guy no shark filled
get on time Philly on time we gotta get
him on the Pod Phil Hanley yeah we
should
used to be a model what I didn't know
that in Vancouver home of the mountain
lion
absolutely
too much of your time
anywhere we're gonna do three episodes
uh plug anything you want guys uh guys
we're on tour uh the state trashy tour
we're just like 20 cities in the next
three months get your tickets at
rdgarverage.com we co-headline the shows
and then play YG with the crowd it's a
good time don't even try to get them
after the show they got to go to the
next city no we do meet and greets
m g is Big yeah yeah it's fun meeting
all the people I love doing it some
places the venues if you're doing two
shows you can't turn them and it's it
kind of stinks the only thing that's
tough with the mean breed sometimes when
you do them you gotta at least when I
would do them you come out on the stage
and do them and then sometimes I just
feel weird walking out to when there's
people just waiting there yeah yeah just
watching you meet everyone watching what
you say to each person online and you
kind of switch it up so you don't feel
like an idiot right well we saw Whitney
we opened up uh for Whitney and Houston
Philly yeah in the bathtub and she uh
she does a thing where uh at the end of
the show she's like if you want to come
up and take a picture just like walk up
to the stage and then she'll just do
like this because you can't really do
them at theaters and stuff like that
yeah
it's just like it's a half ass nothing
crazy just bends down does them do some
selfies it was a good way I was like oh
I've never seen it I drew my I met for
the first time Drew Michael great comic
great kid he was in Portland same time
as me he doesn't meet and greet after
the show every single show he does with
as many people as you want he just stays
there he does a meet and greet like if
he has a seven and a nine he does the
meet and greet after the show the entire
time until he's ready to go on stage for
the next show so there's you know that's
what it is I did that for years and it
just you can't do it it's not
sustainable it's because you get sick
you lose your voice it just wears you
out and he does it for free
I did it for free in the beginning yeah
I did it for free we still do yeah
homies
yeah I did I was doing them for free and
then I was doing them paid I was doing
them paid and free I didn't like the way
I felt doing and paid and then three I
was getting two exhausted so now what I
always do what I always tell everybody I
tell you on stage wear the back door is
and if you want to go I'm walking out of
that thing in 15 minutes I'll take
pictures with you oh that's pretty cool
that's good as many people as I can or
you know some people who want to come
yeah we always we always try to do them
except when you can't sometimes it's
just like logistically with the club the
club's like we can't we have to turn
this room do we just can't we love them
it's [__] it's awesome everybody oh
it's funny it's a good time check these
guys out check out that podcast I've
been on two times I was on this past
week so is there anyone to watch it
because he's done it to three times two
or three times yeah yeah most fun
awesome new students yeah all right
thank you guys so much
thank you so much thank you we did three
full episodes
thank you love it peace
[Music]
hey babe